all right now we're gonna have a funky
good time y'all know that's yeah yeah i
know i know i know
i know all right there's a special event
starting this month that is sure to get
you dancing and have you singing your
heart out with vocalists like elisa
fiorillo and james d train williams and
they are both here with us to invite us
to soul full sundays at the industrial
welcome to las vegas now
from new york from philly that's right
what's it like to be in vegas with a
residency
a beautiful thing we want to bring seoul
to this town come on on sundays it's the
perfect time you don't get up too early
the next day exactly exactly now what
makes
a sunday soulful to you
d train to me soulful was always
something
something that had to do something with
the inner spirit you know for me soulful
was always church
you know i grew up in a gospel situation
but soulful
became more musically diverse when i got
into clubs and started seeing how
different people operate
and then as i grew into music and
started to write
soulful became blue eyed soul
and i realized that it wasn't just james
brown it was michael mcdonald it was joe
cocker
of which we're going to be doing yeah
i know our one of our camera guys josh
he is a huge soul music fan he just
passed out when he saw you in studio
you know age groups coming together and
and still being able to rock out to this
music so talk about the show the first
one is on sunday what can we expect
sunday is seven o'clock um the
industrial it's an amazing event center
and we're just happy to be one of their
first big residencies there
um we've got chaka khan of course prince
because i saw him no i was just going to
ask you about that i want to know how
that was little michael jackson in there
you know we're gonna get people moving
and grooving and i am kicking my shoes
off in the second half of the show just
like patty philly silly girl that i am
because i'm getting
digging my feet in oh my god what was it
like
working with him working with prince
he was the best teacher i ever had wow
and such a giving wonderful man
learned so much so i wanted my band and
i wanted to work with somebody like d
train
just to have that that feeling again of
being on stage and just
jamming with the greatest musicians in
vegas now how long have you guys known
each other well that's a story that
there's a lot
there's a story
no not very long at all um i got a call
from their keyboard player mars who
plays in the band and he said he called
me up and he says uh d trained prince
wants your blessing and i was like
prince who
i'm thinking prince marky d funky bunch
he said
tea tree
the french
oh yeah
tell him he has my blessing and uh he
wound up doing my hit single you're the
one for me and uh lisa was singing
backgrounds on lopez at night
that was george lopez's final
show and then
many years later he passed away
and i wound up
getting a call from the boston pop
symphony orchestra and they were like
well d train we want you to go on the
road with us and i was like for what
they're like we want you to sing purple
rain
oh
so then i moved to vegas
in okay and then i met
that is incredible now is this a family
show or is this only for the grown and
sexy women
okay and it's it's over early so like i
said you can go to work on monday and
right and not be like tired and it's
just such a fun fun night we're excited
that's incredible now i know we're gonna
we're gonna get a little taste of
soulful sundays right now right uh-huh
so before this interview we decided to
write a little jingle oh we got our over
here so it goes a little something like
this like this yes it does come and get
you so full
at seven pm on sunday
industrial
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys just came up with just came up
with that that is pure talent i don't
know how you guys do what you do thank
you both for joining us thank you for
having us we'll see you on sundays all
right
i don't know